by the way you were right yeah you were
right look you didn't need it look how
quickly you recovered look what the
mainstream media uh did when Joe Rogan
announced he had covid and how he was
going to take care of himself and turns
out I got Co so we immediately threw the
kitchen sink at it all kinds of meds
monoclonal antibodies uh ior meon
zpac uh prednizone
everything did you catch what CNN did
right there did you see the color of Joe
Rogan's face on the CNN version of that
he looked completely fine and normal and
had a reddish Hue uh when he went on his
experimental
medications uh and uh when CNN put him
on he was green so this is just another
way that they do all these things and by
the way then what happened at the exact
same time as all of this was unfolding
suddenly for two weeks the entire
mainstream media was calling Joe Rogan
racist because they Unearthed videos of
him saying the nedward even though as
you know he was not saying it in a
racist way he was saying it to mock the
people who actually are racist uh but
who's been the number one guy going
after Aaron roders as Aaron roders has
woke up well it is uh I would say
government mouthpiece quote unquote
comedian Jimmy Kimmel and you may
remember this one from his show at the
height of Co this this is one like if
you look at all of the late night crap
that we can show you and throwback to
during Co this might be the single worst
moment Dr fouchi said that if hospitals
get any more overcrowded they're going
to have to make some very tough choices
about who gets an ICU bet and that
choice doesn't seem so tough to me
vaccinated person having a heart attack
yes come right on him we'll take care of
you unvaccinated guy who gobbled horse
goo rest in peace Wheezy you're think of
the level of evil that I know you've
seen that clip before I mean that is
deeply deeply evil it's against the
hypocritic oath and we now know that the
vaccines didn't even work and the heart
attack that the vaccinated person might
be having might been because of uh the
vaccine in the first place so who's a
worse person who got more of the stuff
wrong and wanted to take out their anger
throughout all of this on other people
is it Aaron Rodgers and Joe Rogan or is
it a guy like Jimmy Kimmel uh anyway
Aaron Rogers continued yesterday to talk
about what's the motivation of the
people who did things like Jimmy Kimmel
yeah it's just on and on and on through
this whole thing my thing is this is you
know all of us who've been attacked for
our
position to all those people what do you
think the motivation is yeah I
mean you know just look at my own
situation like I lost friends allies in
the media millions of dollars on
sponsorship because I talked about what
worked for me and my own beliefs and my
own health reasons why I didn't get
vaccinated oh by the way you were right
yeah you were right look you didn't need
it look how quick you recovered you're
fine and same with you yeah and what did
they do they Chang the color of your
face they they vilified all early
treatments including a medicine that's
has one of the safest profiles out there
that the we've talked about the guy who
invented it got a Nobel Prize they were
using it all over the world in U Pradesh
in Africa and various places and that's
what you do during the pandemic right
you find ways to repurpose drugs for
early treatments but no they couldn't do
that cuz if there's an early treatment
then they can't get the UA proven to
have antiviral properties yeah but
what's the motivation for Peter McCulla
who got vilified what's the motivation
for Robert Mone like well if you know
Peter McCulla Peter McCulla is like that
guy has standards and morals and ethics
I mean he is a rock solid actually
treated patients too actually treated
patients he's also the most published
doctor in history yeah in his particular
field of study the point of all of this
guys is that when you stand up there is
going to be a cost obviously it quite
literally cost Aaron roders millions of
dollars at the height of covid I could
not go into Studios and do interviews
with people right I have no doubt it
cost sponsorship and all those things
did I largely become right about covid
and vaccines and everything else yes and
then over time in the last two plus
years our show has grown and grown and
grown and grown because then people were
like oh Dave seems like he's roughly a
trustworthy guy and kind of at least
directionally get things right so I'll
tune into
that